this video is sponsored by audible to
get a free audio book like game of
thrones or dune or wheel of time sign up
for a trial at the link below
game of thrones author george martin
said he likes tyrion lannister tyrion is
the villain of course but there's
nothing like a good villain
the first few seasons of the thrones tv
show are a pretty close adaptation of
the books tyrion is a smart funny dwarf
who uses his wits in politics but feels
rejected and unloved when he's condemned
for a crime that he didn't commit he
kills his father tywin and his lover
shay
but after season four tyrion in the show
becomes a totally different character to
tyrion in the books in the show tyrion
joins daenerys because he believes she
will make the world better he tries to
help her take the throne without killing
innocent people and without killing his
siblings cersei and jaime but tyrion's
plans all fail his peace in marine fails
his war plans fail his cersei deal fails
and his plan for king's landing fails
when daenerys burns the city
tyrion used to be a smart and ruthless
political player but he spends most of
the last two seasons just standing
around looking sad and helpless
in the finale he tells jon to kill dany
and he says bran should be king and then
everything's
sort of okay in the end
tyrion's story was about his use of
political power and his need for love
and family but the ending of the show
doesn't resolve these themes he fails
politically but still gets power and his
family dies and no one loves him but
he's just kind of okay still he doesn't
change or grow as a character in the
show and he barely impacts the story
about from the last 30 minutes the final
line of dialogue in game of thrones is
tyrion telling a joke but we don't hear
the punchline which is a good metaphor
for tyrion's story
there's a great setup in the first few
seasons but there's no punchline no
emotional payoff in the end
because tyrion in the show is not the
real tyrion lannister in the books his
story is very different and much darker
after killing tywin and shay tyrion is
traumatized and angry he doesn't want to
protect cersei and jaime he wants to
kill his siblings for revenge and he
doesn't want to protect innocent people
he wants to bring fire and sword to
westeros he thinks of himself as a
vengeful ghost coming to haunt the seven
kingdoms they would not love me living
so let them dread me dead
so what is tyrion's story in the books
and is tyrion lannister a villain
tyrion in the books looks very different
to peter dinklage in the show
book tyrion is ugly he has a brutish
squashed in face he's described as
grotesque like a gargoyle his hair is
pale blonde and his eyes are two
different colors one green and one black
when tyrion is wounded in battle he
doesn't just get a cool scar half of his
nose is cut off leaving his face
hideously disfigured
and tyrion's ugliness is important
because it's part of why people reject
him and see him as a monster
one of the inspirations behind tyrion's
character is richard iii who was a king
of england in the wars of the roses in
histories and literature richard was
portrayed as a devious villain who
killed his family to gain power and
supposedly richard was ugly and deformed
with a hunchback his evil soul was
reflected in an ugly twisted body
modern historians doubt whether any of
that was true about richard but the
point is that because of tyrion's ugly
appearance people are prejudiced against
him tyrion was rejected from the day he
was born
tyrion's father tywin was always proud
and ambitious but tywin's father lord
tytos was weak his lords mocked and
laughed at him to his face young tywin
hated the humiliation and shame that
this brought to their noble family so
tywin fought to restore the pride and
power of house lannister brutally
exterminating whole families who
rebelled against them tywin became lord
of casterly rock and hand of the king
for aerys targaryen tywin married his
cousin joanna and he loved her deeply it
said that only she saw the real tywin
beneath his cold harsh armor
they had twins cersei and jaime tywin
wanted cersei to be queen and jaime a
great knight he dreamed they'd be so
strong and brave and beautiful that no
one would ever laugh at them after the
humiliation of his father taitos
laughter was what tywin hated most but
then joanna died giving birth to tyrion
an ugly malformed dwarf king aerys
mocked tywin and said tyrion was a
punishment from the gods that they took
tywin's beautiful wife and gave him a
monster to teach him humility the small
folk called tyrion lord tywin's doom
so tyrion's birth hurt the two things
tywin loved most it undermined the pride
and dignity of house lannister and
caused the death of his beloved wife so
tywin always hated tyrion and was cold
and cruel to him cersei copied her
father and also hated tyrion the only
immediate family who showed tyrion any
affection or respect was his brother
jaime jaime gave him toys and taught him
to ride a pony and tyrion loved and
trusted jaime more than anyone he also
liked his uncles tiggert and gerion
gerion taught tyrion about the wonders
of the world and taught him acrobatics
like flips and walking on his hands
but tywin hated tyrion acting like a
fool and being laughed at so he stopped
the acrobatics tywin also refused to let
tyrion travel with gerion and instead
put tyrion in charge of the drains and
systems at casterly rock
so tyrion had a lonely childhood finding
comfort in books about history and
dragons rejected by his father and his
sister and with no mother tyrion
desperately wanted to be loved
when tyrion was 13 he met a common girl
called taisha they fell in love and got
married happily living as husband and
wife for two weeks
but when tywin found out he was furious
that tyrion had shamed house lannister
by marrying an unworthy woman
jaime told tyrion that taisha was a
[ __ ] that jaime paid taisha to be with
tyrion and that she didn't really love
him to teach tyrion a lesson tywin had
taisha raped by his guards
then he made tyrion rape taisha and the
marriage was ended
so the one time that tyrion fell in love
with someone he learned that that love
wasn't real he was betrayed humiliated
and forced to violate and dehumanize his
wife
ever since taisha tyrion believed that
no woman would ever truly love him that
they'd only want him for his gold so
tyrion turns to sex workers and wine but
tyrion says that while [ __ ] will [ __ ]
you they won't kiss you
he craves real intimacy and approval and
a place in the world he's not a warrior
like jaime he doesn't have power like
tywin he's not feared or loved but he is
smart he's good at strategy and
manipulating people so tyrion reads lots
of books he says his mind is his weapon
and his wits are all he has
when tyrion is about 25 years old book
one begins he goes up to winterfell with
king robert and the rest and he makes
friends with jon snow
in the books tyrion does an acrobatic
jump and somersault here which author
george martin later said he could have
left out because it's kind of silly but
jon feels like an outcast for being a
bastard just like tyrion feels rejected
for being a dwarf so he gives jon advice
he says when people make fun of you and
call you names you should take that name
and make it your armor so like when
people mock tyrion and call him the imp
tyrion takes on the persona of a
sarcastic cynical imp he uses jokes and
irony as a shield to deflect the hurt of
rejection and he uses his sharp tongue
to make fun of people back tyrion slaps
joffrey for being a dick he stands up
for jon against the bullying alisa
thorne and defeats alissa in a mighty
jewel with a crab fork
tyrion gives bran a special saddle
design so he can ride a horse after his
injury tyrion has sympathy for cripples
bastards and broken things he identifies
with underdogs and outcasts
but tyrion can also be cruel and
vindictive even in small ways like he
dislikes benjen stark so tyrion takes
benjen's warm clothes to make benjen
cold just out of petty spite when
catelyn captures tyrion he plots revenge
on all her men he especially hates the
singer marillion for making fun of him
so when they're attacked tyrion stomps
on marillion's hand and breaks his
fingers just cause he's annoyed by this
guy's singing
lysa falsely accuses tyrion of murder
and it's easy to frame tyrion because
he's an ugly imp and people are biased
against him but tyrion escapes using his
wits and his words he convinces brawn
and the mountain clansmen to join him
tyrion says he'll help the mountain
clansmen attack the veil and in the
books he's serious about this he plans
to reduce the veil of aaron to a smoking
wasteland he thinks there's nothing he'd
enjoy more than getting revenge on lysa
except perhaps strangling cersei
he often fantasizes about killing cersei
and tywin even as a child he dreamed of
burning his sister and father in dragon
fire
so from the beginning book tyrion has a
dark side that wasn't in the tv show
being mistreated and disrespected makes
him angry and he wants to pay his debts
with violent revenge
tyrion meets with his father tywin as
the lannisters go to war with the starks
and tullys and tywin fights this war in
the most violent and destructive way
possible he orders his most brutal
soldiers like the mountain to burn and
plunder the riverlands killing and
raping innocent people and tyrion
doesn't question this he's there when
tywin gives these orders he sees
villages burned he sees innocent people
killed by his family and tyrion has no
sympathy because tyrion thinks like
tywin does it was tywin who taught
tyrion that a lannister pays his debts
with brutal indiscriminate violence i
see you have taken a few lessons from me
tywin says and that's why tyrion wants
violent revenge on marillion and the
vale and ironically on taiwan tyrion
does hate tywin but he's still so
desperate for his father's love and
approval that he's internalized tywin's
brutal methods and tries to be like him
but no matter how hard tyrion tries
tywin just criticizes and humiliates
tyrion saying he's weak and useless
tywin's constant negging makes tyrion
feel insecure inadequate and unloved
tywin orders tyrion to fight on the
front lines of a battle and tyrion
realizes that his father wants to get
him killed so before the battle tyrion
feels lonely and he meets a girl called
shay who agrees to be his lover in
return for gold shea is just 18 years
old in the books she's witty and
charming and when they have sex she acts
like she enjoys it and calls him her
giant of lannister
tyrion knows that she's just pretending
to like him but he's so desperate for
love that he wants to believe it's real
in the tv show shea eventually does love
tyrion for real but not in the books
author george martin says shea doesn't
give a [ __ ] about tyrion and is only in
it for the money and status and tyrion
knows this but after his experience with
taisha he feels that fake love is all he
can get
at the battle in the tv show tyrion gets
knocked out and misses the whole thing
because the showrunners didn't have the
budget for a battle in season one but in
the books tyrion rides in and fights he
kills some blokes and stabs a horse with
his hat and he survives this battle so
tywin gives tyrion a hint of praise and
respect for once he tells tyrion to go
to king's landing and rule as hand over
the king but tywin also tells tyrion not
to bring his [ __ ] shay
the talk of [ __ ] brings up tyrion's
anger and pain over what tywin did to
taisha so tyrion defies his father and
brings shay to king's landing
so in book one tyrion is hurt and angry
at a world that rejects him he wants
love and respect
and revenge
in book two tyrion takes power in king's
landing and says he's going to do
justice he gets rid of the corrupt
slint because janos's men killed a baby
and her mother tyrion imprisons and
humiliates pycelle for disobeying him
tyrion blackmails lancel lannister and
bribes the kettleblacks to spy on cersei
he sends myrcella to go marry a martel
and makes a plan to free jaime from the
starks tyrion feels very impressed with
himself for all his clever political
plots he thinks that he can scheme with
any man that this is what he was made
for but he's not really as successful as
he thinks like sure tyrion outsmarts
janos and pycelle and lancel but those
guys are small fry the real dangerous
players are littlefinger and varys and
tyrion never figures out what they're up
to and many of tyrion's plots fail the
kettleblacks were working for
littlefinger all along not tyrion
myrcella's marriage just lets the
martels use her against the lannisters
tyrion's plot to free jaime fails and
tyrion's insults to pycelle and joffrey
and the kingsguard and others just
create enemies who turn against tyrion
in the end so tyrion is not as clever as
he thinks he is and he doesn't really do
justice like sure he gets rid of janos
or just makes him jon snow's problem but
the person who ordered janos to kill a
baby was cersei and tyrion feels he
can't bring cersei to justice
tyrion also realizes that his own men
like bronn are just as cutthroat and
immoral as janos was so he admits to
himself that he isn't really doing
justice
ultimately tyrion works as hand of the
king for king joffrey a cruel
incompetent child tyrant tyrion knows
that joffrey is a terrible king and he
knows that he isn't the rightful king
joffrey is a bastard of incest making
stannis the true king tyrion knows that
cersei and tywin are cruel terrible
rulers and he knows that their army
commits evil atrocities in the
riverlands a riverlord says that
lannister soldiers are burning raping
and killing innocent people and tyrion
doesn't care he says that's just war
which is a [ __ ] excuse the starks
and tullys and stannis don't wage war
like that the lannisters are
exceptionally brutal in between tyrion's
chapters we get chapters from arya's
perspective as she experiences the
horror of lannister atrocities making it
really clear that tyrion is on the wrong
side of this war all his clever
political plots support a brutal
illegitimate government fighting against
the heroic starks and righteous stannis
tyrion also mostly ignores the threat of
the white walker apocalypse even though
the night's watch repeatedly asks him
for help
tyrion doesn't do justice in book 2.
it's not about the realm
it's about his ego
after a lifetime of being mocked and
disrespected tyrion loves having power
and status he thinks me the dwarf the
monster the one they scorned and laughed
at now i hold it all the power the city
the girl and i do love it
tyrion's humiliation of lansel and
pycelle isn't about political strategy
it's about making himself feel powerful
making himself feel tall
tyrion's feelings of resentment are
understandable and sympathetic but he
uses his power to bully and humiliate to
feed his ego and to fight on the wrong
side of this war that's why tyrion is
the villain in book two
throughout the book tyrion struggles for
power with cersei they're both on team
lannister they both want the same things
but they each want the power for
themselves so they undermine and lie and
insult and spy on each other there is
one moment when tyrion and cersei
celebrate and are happy together but
tyrion uses this opportunity to slip
cersei a mild poison to get rid of her
for a few days and the relationship
really breaks down when tyrion gets
between cersei and her children tyrion
sends myself to dawn he takes tommen
away for safe keeping and he puts
joffrey in a battle
cersei feels that her children are
threatened so she retaliates by
threatening the people tyrion loves she
captures a sex worker called aleja
thinking that she's tyrion's lover shea
and she threatens to torture and kill
the girl if cersei's children are hurt
so how does tyrion react he could tell
cersei the truth that she's got the
wrong girl that tyrion would never hurt
her children that they're on the same
side and shouldn't be fighting but
instead tyrion decides to be like tywin
and to speak with his father's voice so
tyrion says that if aliyah is beaten and
raped tyrion will beat and rape tommen
he promises to hurt cersei to turn her
joy to ashes in her mouth
this is the moment that tyrion and
cersei become enemies and it happens
because instead of being honest
half-decent people they both act like
their brutal ruthless father
their petty sibling rivalry for tywin's
love spirals into murder hate and
eventual disaster for their family
tyrion defends king's landing from
stannis he blows up stannis's ships with
wildfire and in the books he traps the
burning ships with a giant chain
we see it from davos's perspective as
tyrion's wildfire kills his sons and
thousands of others so from davos's
perspective tyrion totally is the
villain
tyrion leads an attack and fights amidst
fiery ships like a badass but then
tyrion's attacked by one of his own men
mandan moore slashes tyrion's face open
possibly under cersei's orders or
joffrey's orders or little fingers he
has a lot of enemies but tyrion goes
down and tywin and the tyrells arrive to
win the battle
at the end of the book tyrion is badly
wounded his face is disfigured and he's
alone
he has fever dreams and visions of the
thousands of people he killed in battle
burned corpses weeping and moaning he
thinks why did i kill them all
and then he dreams the answer he dreams
of a feast where everyone praises him as
a hero jaime makes him a knight shea
embraces him and his father tywin smiles
with approval
this is why tyrion fought this war this
is why he played politics it's because
he wants to be loved
but in book 3 tyrion gets no love
tywin takes all the credit for winning
the battle and takes tyrion's power as
hand of the king tyrion's allies are
replaced and scattered and tyrion feels
abandoned so tyrion goes to his father
and asks for some gratitude and
recognition for saving the city and
bleeding for their family he asks to be
publicly acknowledged as tywin's son and
heir since jaime is a kingsguard tyrion
should be the next lord of costly rock
but tywin refuses he calls tyrion an
ill-made creature devious spiteful and
full of lust he says he'll never let
tyrion turn castly rock into his [ __ ]
house
tywin is angry that tyrion threatened
cersei to protect aliyah so tywin has
aliyeh whipped and kicked out the seedy
gates naked tywin brings up taisha and
shay and says he'll kill tyrion's [ __ ]
so
tywin's hatred of tyrion is connected to
tywin's feelings about women and sex
which goes back to tywin's relationship
with his own father taitos because after
tywin's mother died taitos took several
common women as his mistresses one
mistress became proud and influential
ordering people around at casterly rock
and she wore tywin's mother's clothes
and jewelry
tywin was furious that a lowborn woman
had power and status in house lannister
and had replaced his mother wearing her
clothes so when taitos died tywin
stripped the woman and walked her naked
through the streets to show the world
she was a [ __ ]
now tywin does the same thing with
aliyah and did something similar with
taisha
because of his daddy issues tywin is
paranoid about lower-class women
undermining his pride and shaming his
noble house so he uses brutal sexual
violence and public humiliation to put
women beneath the dignity of his house
that's why tywin hates that tyrion
openly has sex with low-born women like
taitos did he hates that tyrion is
mocked and laughed at like taitos was
tywin says i was made to suffer my
father's follies i will not suffer yours
tyrion reminds tywin of all his deepest
insecurities about his father and women
and his grief for his wife it's not fair
or rational but that's why tywin hates
tyrion and rejects him so brutally
tyrion knows that shay is in danger from
tywin and that it'd be safer to send her
away but she's the only person who makes
him feel loved even though he knows that
she's just using him for his money
shay is not a nice person in the books
she says some cruel things about lollis
a disabled rape victim and tyrion is
unkind to shay sometimes he slaps her
once he isolates and controls her he
risks the life of this teenage girl for
his gratification and then tyrion gets
in another shitty relationship with a
teenager
tywin tells tyrion to marry sansa stark
so that the lannisters can use her claim
to take over the north and tyrion has
mixed feelings he says sansa is too
young to marry because she's just 12
years old in the books but tyrion would
like to rule winterfell and get away
from his family tyrion offers for sansa
to marry lancel instead but sansa
remembers that tyrion was kind to her
once and she hasn't really got a choice
anyway so they both go along with the
wedding sansa refuses to kneel for the
wedding cloak though so tyrion has to
stand on the back of a jester the
wedding is humiliating and depressing
for them both tyrion gets drunk and
threatens king joffrey and then they go
to bed
tywin told tyrion to have sex with sansa
to consummate the marriage to secure
their claim on the north and at first
tyrion intends to have sex with her but
sansa doesn't want him so he relents and
they settle into their distant
uncomfortable marriage
tyrion tries to connect with her he's so
desperate to be wanted but she doesn't
want him because she's 12 and she's a
political prisoner and tyrion's family
killed her family so their marriage is a
daily agony tywin keeps telling tyrion
to have sex with sansa and tyrion's
angry that his father keeps trying to
control his sex life a singer blackmails
tyrion so tyrion has him killed and made
into soup
tyrion's stressed he has a shitty job as
master of coin there are martels and
tyrells to deal with his child wife
hates him his dad wants to kill his
girlfriend the queen hates him the king
hates him the common people hate him and
think he's a twisted little monkey demon
house lannister is more powerful than
ever but tyrion feels miserable and
alone
at joffrey's wedding there's a
performance by some dwarfs who ride a
dog and a pig and joust for
entertainment joffrey tells tyrion to
ride the pig and tyrion refuses so they
get angry and insult each other publicly
then joffrey dies of poisoned wine and
cersei accuses tyrion of the murder
at the trial tyrion has no friends to
defend him braun gets bribed by cersei
and podrick is just a boy what tyrion
does have is a lot of enemies all the
people tyrion threatened and humiliated
over the last two books come back to
condemn him
and they make a strong case that tyrion
poisoned joffrey because tyrion did
steal poison and he did threaten joffrey
he publicly swore to geld joffrey
of course tyrion didn't really intend to
cut off his nephew's penis just like he
didn't really want to hurt tommen he
only made those threats because he was
angry and hurt and because he thought
that acting like tywin and playing the
role of a monster would protect him like
armor
but it really doesn't work tyrion says
he's been on trial for being a dwarf all
his life and it's true that people are
horribly prejudiced against him for the
way that he looks but it's also true
that tyrion's villainous behavior his
threats and manipulation and lies are
part of why people treat him like a
villain
finally shea testifies against tyrion
after being bribed and pressured by
cersei shea says tyrion is guilty and
she humiliates him by talking about
their sex life
this betrayal breaks tyrion and all his
hatred pours out he says he wants to
poison everyone that he wishes he was
the monster they think he is
tyrion demands trial by combat but the
mountain kills oberyn so tywin condemns
his son to death for a crime he didn't
commit
before his execution tyrion is saved by
jaime and this is the moment when tyrion
in the show and tyrion in the books go
in completely different directions
because in the show tyrion thanks jaime
and they hug lovingly then tyrion leaves
but in the books jaime makes a terrible
revelation
after tyrion married taisha jaime had
told him that taisha was a [ __ ] that
jaime paid her to be with tyrion and
that she didn't really love him but now
jaime reveals that that was a lie that
tywin made him tell
jaime didn't pay taisha she was just a
random peasant girl who really did love
tyrion
all these years tyrion thought that no
woman would ever love him but now he
finds out that his wife who was gang
raped by tywin's men and by tyrion was
the only woman who ever loved him
tyrion is devastated and furious that
jaime kept to this lie it feels like the
ultimate betrayal from the one person
tyrion thought he could trust
all tyrion's pain becomes rage and he
swears to get revenge on his family to
punish the world by becoming the villain
that they think he is
he says i am the monster they all say i
am and just to hurt jaime he says he did
kill joffrey and tells him that cersei's
been cheating on him
so tyrion leaves jaime not as a loving
brother but as his enemy a monster
wanting revenge and it's because of the
revelation about taisha that tyrion goes
after tywin
in tywin's bed tyrion finds shay
tywin had always criticized tyrion for
having sex with [ __ ] he says it's a
weakness and a shame on their family
after tywin's wife died he supposedly
never touched a woman he had no use for
[ __ ] tywin acted like he had no lust
no emotions just cold rationality but
now tyrion sees that's a lie
tywin does have sex with common women
just like tyrion and it's not just shay
in book two tyrion uses a secret tunnel
that runs into a brothel varys says that
this tunnel was built for a hand of the
king so that he could visit the brothel
secretly and inside the brothel is a red
and yellow window and a globe of gilded
metal and scarlet glass those are
lannister colours and tywin lannister
was hand of the king so it was probably
tywin who built this tunnel to visit the
brothel on the regular tywin even lets
shae wear his jewelry just like his
father's mistress wore his mother's
jewelry
so there are some deep dark complicated
feelings about sex and family and shame
going on in taiwan but the point is that
tyrion discovers that tywin is a massive
hypocrite who does have sex with [ __ ]
just like tyrion does
in the show when tyrion finds shay shay
grabs a knife and they struggle before
tyrion kills her then tyrion cries and
apologizes to the corpse the show tries
to make the scene feel tragic almost
sympathetic to tyrion but in the books
it's cold-blooded murder shay doesn't
grab a knife shea cries and says she
didn't want to betray tyrion that cersei
made her and tywin scares her
but tyrion is angry at her betrayal so
he strangles her to death without mercy
compared to the show this is a much more
cold brutal murder author george martin
calls it tyrion's blackest deed the
great crime of his soul
then tyrion gets a crossbow and finds
his noble father on the toilet he asks
tywin what happened to taisha where did
she go after the gang rape tywin doesn't
know and doesn't care he says taisha
went
wherever [ __ ] go
so tyrion shoots his father
tywin says tyrion is no son of mine but
tyrion says i'm you rit small meaning
i'm just like you
cause tywin hated tyrion for being
devious spiteful and lustful but it
turns out tywin is just as devious and
spiteful and lustful as tyrion tywin is
devious when he plots the red wedding he
is spiteful when he had elia martell
killed and the reigns and castemieres
and he's so goddamn lustful that he
roots his son's girlfriend and builds a
secret personal sex tunnel to a brothel
tywin and tyrion have the same
insecurities about being laughed at and
feeling weak and ashamed tywin tries to
hide his feelings behind the image of a
noble cold golden lion someone who's
above the petty shameful behavior of his
dwarf son but it's a lie it's all
[ __ ] and that's why tywin dies
[ __ ] himself on the toilet tywin did
not in the end [ __ ] gold because he's
not a golden lion he is a deeply flawed
man full of shame and spite and lust
just like his son tyrion
in book three tyrion tries to be loved
by his family and shay and sansa but he
is betrayed and condemned by everyone
close to him
so in book five tyrion goes east
drinking his way across the sea he is
consumed with self-loathing anger and
despair he's lost everything he no
longer dreams of love or justice all he
has left is hatred he wants to kill
jaime and cersei and bring war to
westeros he wants to punish the world
for rejecting him and he especially
hates women tyrion threatens a slave
girl saying he'll have sex with her and
murder her just for the pleasure of
making her afraid
tyrion's in a very dark place and he
reacts to his trauma and pain by hurting
others and himself
in pentos tyrion meets illyrio who's
working with varys to help daenerys
conquer westeros he convinces tyrion to
join daenerys so that tyrion can get
revenge on the lannisters and take
casterly rock for himself
so tyrion travels with a group of
illyrio's allies led by this guy griff
and this kid young griff there's also a
scepter and a scholar and a knight and
tyrion figures out that griff and his
crew are not who they seem griff is
actually john connington who was once a
lord in westeros and young griff is
actually supposedly aegon targaryen the
son of prince rhaegar and elia martel
who everyone thought was dead griff and
illyrio and varys have raised aegon to
be king they hope to marry him to
daenerys so that they can conquer and
rule westeros together
so the group travel downriver and see
some wondrous sights there's a giant
turtle a naked nun and a strange shape
in the fog that may or may not be a
dragon
in the sorrows they see the ancient
ruins of the bridge of dream and the
palace of love just like tyrion's dreams
and loves are now ruined which is one of
george martin's less subtle metaphors
the sorrows are a strange and spooky
place said to be ruled by a dark
mystical figure called the shrouded lord
their boat inexplicably magically goes
through the same place twice and then
they're attacked by stone men people
infected with greyscale tyrion saves
aegon john connington saves tyrion and
joncon gets infected with greyscale but
keeps it a secret in the tv show jorah
gets greyscale but in the books it's jon
conn and the disease makes jonkon
desperate to make aegon king of westeros
asap because joncon was in love with
aegon's father prince rhaegar he feels
guilty for failing rhaegar and he wants
to redeem himself by getting aegon on
the throne he and his crew have spent
years training and protecting aegon in
secret and now it's almost time to
reveal him and claim his birthright
but tyrion really doesn't give a [ __ ]
about joncon and aegon's quest he makes
fun of aegon's whole story as a perfect
handsome fantasy prince and he
undermines the noble heroism with his
sarcasm and cynicism and hate it's
almost matter how tyrion mocks the
fantasy tropes of the story that he's in
like rick sanchez being so depressed and
disillusioned and drunk that he breaks
the fourth wall a little tyrion even
dresses in motley like a jester a
villainous fool who makes fun of the
world like an edgy westerosi joker
tyrion hates jon khan because he reminds
him of tywin and aegon is an annoying
hot-headed teenager so tyrion
mischievously messes with their plans
over a game of sevas which is the game
of thrones version of chess tyrion
manipulates aegon and convinces him to
change his plan instead of going east
and joining forces with daenerys he
tells aegon to go west and attack
westeros by himself and since aegon is
young and rash and jonkon is impatient
with his greyscale the mad lads actually
do it they abandon the plan and attack
westeros without daenerys
tyrion doesn't actually think this is a
good idea he only suggests it to mess
with them and create chaos but this
decision could have huge consequences
like if aegon takes the throne himself
he and daenerys could end up becoming
enemies instead of allies there are
hints that aegon is not really a
targaryen he's actually a blackfyre and
daenerys is warned of a mummer's dragon
or false dragon there are hints of a war
between them a dance of the dragons that
will cause death and destruction across
westeros so tyrion's trolling might
cause a terrible war and he doesn't care
he laughs when he finds out in his anger
and nihilism tyrion wants to see the
world burn
tyrion is haunted by memories of tywin
and shay and taisha
since taisha was the one woman who truly
loved him he wants to find her again he
imagines them living together in their
cottage like they did when they were
young and happy it's not a realistic
dream but that distant memory is all
he's got
tywin said that taisha went wherever
horse goes so tyrion repeatedly asks
where do horse go
thinking of taisha he visits a brothel
and he has sex with a slave prostitute
who has dead eyes and a scarred back
tyrion feels wretched full of shame and
guilt he drinks till he pukes tells the
slave to kill him and then has sex with
her again even though she clearly
doesn't want to he rapes her
but in the tv show version of the scene
tyrion is charming and nice a slave
offers him free sex but tyrion declines
because he's so sad in like a noble kind
of way
the show whitewashes tyrion it takes out
the bad stuff he does and makes him into
a bland good guy who doesn't change as a
character but the books go deep into
tyrion's emotional devastation and he
does terrible things
tyrion is captured by jorah who wants to
give him to daenerys to get back in her
favor and they go to volantis an ancient
slave city in a state of political
unrest because the rulers of volantis
plan to attack daenerys because daenerys
is fighting against slavery but the
slaves of volantis see daenerys as a
beacon of freedom and the red priests
preach the daenerys is the prophesied
saviour azor ahai
a woman called the widow of the
waterfront tells tyrion that the slaves
are waiting for daenerys to come and
free them tyrion agrees to go and help
daenerys but not for heroic reasons he
says he'll bring daenerys his hate and
the only reward he asks for is to be
allowed to rape and kill his sister
cersei
tyrion embraces the role of a monstrous
villain over in braavos arya is in a
play where the tyrion character says as
i cannot be the hero let me be the
monster
and lessen them in fear in place of love
then tyrion is attacked by a dwarf girl
called penny penny was one of the
performers back at joffrey's wedding but
when tyrion escaped westeros cersei put
a bounty on tyrion's head so a bunch of
idiot bounty hunters have killed
innocent dwarfs thinking they might be
tyrion penny's brother oppo was one of
those killed and in her grief and anger
penny blames tyrion
tyrion takes pity on penny and brings
her with them as they sail east
eventually tyrion and penny reconcile
and become friends they've got a lot in
common they're both dwarfs who have lost
their families and their ways of life
they're both dealing with grief anger
and suicidal thoughts
but unlike tyrion penny moves past her
anger she forgives tyrion for her
brother's death and instead of wallowing
in hatred and despair like tyrion penny
is optimistic with hopes and dreams for
the future
penny tells tyrion to stop his
self-destructive behavior like tyrion
makes fun of jorah until jorah hits
tyrion and penny tells him he's got to
stop provoking people or he'll get
himself killed it used to be that tyrion
could say what he liked because he was a
rich and powerful nobleman but now as an
exile he's no one so when he talks [ __ ]
he gets hit
tyrion has always felt sorry for himself
but he was very lucky to be born into a
rich noble family he's been protected by
his privilege all his life but penny is
a common person as well as a dwarf and
she's learned the hard way how to
survive
tyrion hates being laughed at but penny
says that making people laugh can be a
good thing in fact if tyrion had ridden
her pig at joffrey's wedding like
joffrey asked instead of insulting
joffrey tyrion might never have been
condemned and penny's brother might
still be alive
no one should have to put up with
humiliation but many of tyrion's
problems are caused by his pride
when morale on their ship gets
dangerously low penny convinces tyrion
to perform a joust with her riding her
pig against her dog
so penny challenges tyrion's pride his
privilege and his self-destructive
behavior she shows him that he's not the
only dwarf in the world who's suffered
and that it's possible to forgive and
hope
penny has a crush on tyrion and they
kiss a couple of times but tyrion isn't
interested in her like that the only
woman he loves is his idealized memory
of taisha so tyrion has a complicated
relationship with penny he's protective
of her and kind sometimes but he rejects
her love and he mostly rejects her
positive hopeful attitude tyrion stays
angry and proud and cynical and he moves
closer to power
a red priest called macquaro has a
vision of tyrion with dragons
dragons old and young true and false
bright and dark with tyrion snarling in
their midst a small man with a big
shadow the old dragons could be amon or
bloodraven the young and true dragons
could be daenerys and jon snow who is
probably secretly a targaryen and the
false dark dragon could be aegon because
he might actually be a blackfyre not a
targaryen and through these dragons
tyrion will have a big impact on the
story in book one tyrion cast a shadow
as tall as a king aemon said that tyrion
is a giant come among us here at the end
of the world so there's lots of
foreshadowing that tyrion will play a
big role in the end game of the story
their ship is damaged in a storm
macquaro floats off to victarion and
tyrion penny and jorah are captured by
slavers outside moraine the city is
under siege by the slavers of yonkai
while daenerys tries to negotiate peace
so tyrion penny and jorah are bought as
slaves by a yonkishman called yezanzo
quaggas or the yellow whale yezan is
enormously rich and enormously fat and
he keeps a grotesquery of slaves with
unusual bodies watched over by his cruel
overseer nurse
tyrion has gone from a proud powerful
ruler in westeros to a powerless
humiliated slave
inside marine daenerys tries to make
peace with the slavers by marrying his
da and opening the fighting pits tyrion
and penny are made to perform for the
crowds so the first time tyrion and
daenerys see each other tyrion is riding
a pig though she doesn't know he's
tyrion and they still haven't met
because drogon crashes the party
daenerys flies off and yunkai prepares
to attack marine a disease called the
bloody flux breaks out and yezan gets
sick yezan was dying already from an
exotic disease he got in sothoryos so
pretty soon he's squirting his guts out
and tyrion takes the opportunity to
escape
on the way out he kills nurse with some
poison mushrooms and says a lannister
always pays his debts
so after all the crazy stuff that
happens in this book tyrion is still a
lannister still proud spiteful and
murderous like his father the main way
that tyrion has changed since the start
of book 5 is that he's less depressed
now he doesn't want to die anymore he
originally considered using these poison
mushrooms to kill himself in pentos but
now he chooses to live and get revenge
tyrion goes to a mercenary captain
called brown ben plum commander of the
second sons tyrion convinces him to let
him and penny and jorah join his company
to escape slavery and in return tyrion
promises ben money and a lordship when
tyrion gets power back in westeros so
tyrion penny and jorah escape slavery
but now they're stuck in the middle of a
battle between the slavers and
daenerys's forces daenerys herself is
still missing in the dothraki sea so
barristan commands her army alongside
grey worm and the unsullied some sell
swords and freed slaves ben plum and the
second sons are on the side of the
slavers but tyrion hopes to convince
them to join daenerys instead
so tyrion's back in the game of thrones
playing politics being a lannister again
and he is as ruthless as ever he
compares himself to tywin and thinks
about poisoning wells tyrion wants to
join daenerys but not because he
believes in her or anything he just
thinks that she's his best hope of
bringing fire and sword to westeros
so in book five tyrion loses everything
and falls deep into despair and hate but
now he's returning to the game of
thrones when he gets power will he use
it for violence and vengeance like tywin
would or will he find forgiveness and
hope like penny
author george martin has released sample
chapters of the upcoming next book the
winds of winter in the opening chapters
tyrion convinces ben plum and his men to
switch sides and join daenerys another
sellsword company called the windblown
also joined daenerys victarion and
macquarie arrive with the ironborn and
attack the slavers the dragons rhaegal
and viserion are loose and sir barristan
rides into battle
so
it looks like daenerys forces will
defeat the slavers leaving a very
strange bunch of characters in charge of
marine
barristan is daenerys's closest ally so
tyrion will want to win his trust though
tyrion suspects that barristan will hate
him for being a villainous kinslayer
victarion wants to marry daenerys and
steal her dragons which probably won't
end well for him but if he survives the
battle we could get some fun dialogue
with tyrion making fun of victarion dumb
as a stump greyjoy mcquoro could teach
tyrion more about magic and prophecy
marwyn the mage should arrive sometime
and he's also into magic and books ben
plum and the tattered prince will want
battle and plunder jorah wants to get
out of the friend zone with daenerys
though he's picked up an unfortunate
face tattoo recently daario is still
around and he wants daenerys and strong
beloss wants liver and onions
it's a colourful collection of
characters and a great opportunity for
tyrion to play politics crack jokes rule
marine and set himself up as an adviser
to daenerys when she returns
daenerys won't trust tyrion right away
because tyrion is a lannister condemned
as a treacherous kingslayer but tyrion
is very good at convincing people to
make alliances and tyrion has lots of
useful information that daenerys needs
daenerys has never been to mainland
westeros she doesn't know her enemies
but tyrion intimately knows cersei jaime
king tommen and other lords tyrion knows
the defenses of king's landing and
casterly rock and tyrion is the only
person in meereen who knows about aegon
and jonkon tyrion can tell her that
aegon is on the way to take her throne
which could convince daenerys to get to
westeros asap tyrion might manipulate
daenerys and convince her that aegon is
her enemy to encourage conflict and
chaos
so like in the show tyrion will probably
become daenerys's hand of the queen but
his advice to daenerys may be very
different to the show in the show tyrion
tells daenerys to be merciful to the
slavers so instead of killing them all
they just kill some and give the rest a
stern talking to but book tyrion in his
anger and hate won't want mercy for the
people who just enslaved him he'll want
revenge book daenerys also wants
violence all through book five she tries
to rule marine peacefully making
compromises marrying his da chaining up
her dragons but peace fails so she flies
off on her dragon and she has visions
reminding her that she is the blood of
the dragon that marine is not her home
that the targaryen words are fire and
blood
daenerys is done with peace she's set to
burn her enemies and daenerys once said
that if yonkai attacks her she will
raise their city to the ground so
daenerys and tyrion's first act together
won't be this half-assed compromise it
might be to destroy yonkai
george martin says that daenerys has
embraced her heritage as a targaryen and
that she and tyrion are coming home
but it's a long way from irene to
westeros and they have unfinished
business in essos the red priests and
the widow of the waterfront want
daenerys to free the slaves of volantis
which might get violent a priest
prophesies that volantis will burn and
conveniently the ruling slavers of
volantis live inside the black walls in
the heart of the city making them a
convenient target for daenerys to roast
them all with dragon fire macquaro may
convince daenerys of her destiny to be a
sword of fire that will cleanse the
world pushing her further towards
violence
daenerys also has business in pentos
because the captain of the wind blown
the tattered prince joins daenerys on
the condition that he gets to take over
pentos daenerys hasn't agreed to this
yet at first she says she won't give
pentos to tatters because illyrio lives
in pentos and illyrio is her trusted
ally
but tyrion can tell daenerys the truth
that illyrio has been lying and
manipulating her all along illyrio
really supports aegon and while illyrio
was selling daenerys to the dothraki he
was raising aegon in secrecy and safety
tyrion could convince daenerys to burn
illyrio for his betrayal and to give
pentos to the tattered prince
we don't know what tata's plans are for
pentos but it's probably something bad
tatters has history with pentos and he's
a cruel and brutal man one time tatters
cut off a guy's foot then forced him to
eat it and then made him his cook that's
the sort of guy tatas is and daenerys
and tyrion might give him the city of
pentos
so there are strong hints in the books
that daenerys's journey across essos
will be violent and destructive bringing
fire and blood across the continent
will tyrion encourage this violence or
will he tell daenerys to be more
peaceful
tyrion's peaceful compassionate side is
represented by his relationship with
penny and in his latest chapters he
rejects her optimism pretty harshly he
slaps her tells her to stop dreaming and
to face harsh reality there are even
hints that tyrion might hurt penny
tyrion dreams of shooting penny with a
crossbow and there's a weird dark moment
when penny reminds tyrion of shea and
he's overwhelmed with rage and tyrion
thinks about killing penny
if tyrion kills penny or just rejects
her or loses her somehow that could be
the breaking point that leads tyrion to
fully embrace daenerys's bloody conquest
and tyrion might develop a connection
with daenerys's dragons tyrion has
always been fascinated with dragons so
he's read a lot of books about them and
this knowledge is considered so valuable
that joncon makes him write down
everything he knows about dragons in
case it's useful so this knowledge is
another way that tyrion can help
daenerys because daenerys doesn't
actually know that much about dragons
she has a lot of trouble controlling
hers in the books they keep disobeying
her and eating children they didn't come
with a manual so tyrion might help
daenerys control her dragons maybe even
breed them or design dragon armor or a
dragon riding saddle like the saddle he
designed for bran
and maybe tyrion will ride a dragon
himself he does dream of riding a dragon
and burning his enemies and author
george martin has hinted that tyrion
will fly
daenerys believes that her three dragons
need three riders jon snow will probably
ride one like he does in the tv show he
rides the green dragon rhaegal who is
named after his father rhaegar daenerys
rides the black dragon drogon so tyrion
could ride viserion viserion is coloured
white and gold and his blood is gold and
red which fits tyrion's lannister
colours at the end of his latest preview
chapter tyrion dramatically picks up a
white dragon's piece which hints at a
connection between him and the white
dragon viserion
usually dragons are only ridden by
targaryens people with the valyrian
blood of the dragon and tyrion isn't a
targaryen
or is he
there is a theory that tyrion is not the
son of tywin lannister he's actually the
son of the mad king aerys targaryen
because for years aerys was sexually
interested in tyrion's mother joanna
lannister it was rumored that he took
her virginity and that she was his
mistress for a while at joanna's wedding
to tywin aerys joked that he wanted to
have sex with her and he took liberties
at the bedding
aerys wife complained that aerys was
turning her ladies into his [ __ ] so
joanna went back to castley rock for a
while but then the year before tyrion
was born aerys and joanna were both at a
tournament in king's landing aerys made
comments about joanna's breasts and
tywin got so angry that he tried to
resign as hand and the next year tyrion
was born
so maybe at this tournament aerys had
sex with joanna and fathered tyrion
being a targaryen could explain tyrion's
pale blonde hair which looks more like
the targaryen silvery blonde than the
lannister golden blonde tyrion's green
eye could be from his lannister mother
and his black eye could actually be a
very dark targaryen purple targaryen
blood could explain why tyrion doesn't
catch greyscale or the bloody flux
because targaryens tend not to get sick
it could explain tyrion's dreams of
dragons which are common in targaryens
and targaryen blood could let tyrion
ride a dragon
in book 5 daenerys dragons like ben plum
and tyrion explains that this is because
ben has some targaryen blood in his
family tree maybe the reason this is
mentioned in the book is so that when
tyrion meets daenerys dragons they'll
like him too hinting that tyrion also
has targaryen blood and then barristan
who was aerys's guard for years could
reveal that aerys is tyrion's father it
all fits the white dragon the timeline
his appearance his dreams tyrion could
be a targaryen
but does the story really need another
secret targaryen we've already got jon
snow probably being a secret targaryen
and young griff being a secret targaryen
or a blackfyre do we really need all
three main characters to be targaryens
whose mothers died in childbirth who
ride dragons
and if tyrion is aerys's son what does
that mean for his relationship with
tywin the whole point of their
relationship is that even though tywin
hates tyrion tyrion is just like tywin
tyrion is tywin ritz small
isn't that ruined if tyrion is actually
aerys's son
you could argue that even if aerys is
tyrion's biological father tywin is the
father who raised tyrion and his shitty
parenting made tyrion who he is
it's like how even if rhaegar is jon
snow's biological father ned stark is
the father who raised jon and made him
the person who he is
and it kind of makes sense if tywin
always suspected that tyrion was aerys's
son cause he does say that tyrion is not
his son but that he just cannot prove
that tyrion isn't his
because there is no proof whether tyrion
is a targaryen there's only hints and
maybe that ambiguity is the point maybe
we'll never know for sure like maybe
tyrion will start to develop a
connection with viserion but then
viserion will be killed or taken by
euron before tyrion can fully explore
his targaryen side
maybe he'll always question his identity
is he a lannister or a targaryen tywin
wandered the same thing he was never
quite sure if tyrion was his son he
didn't want to believe that tyrion was
his because tyrion was a reflection of
everything tywin hated about himself
it's because tyrion is so much like
tywin that tywin denied tyrion was his
son and preferred to believe he was
aerys's instead but tyrion unlike tywin
could face the truth that it doesn't
matter whether aerys is his biological
father tyrion was raised as a lannister
his personality and values were shaped
by tywin so for better or worse no
matter what's in his blood tyrion is
tywin's son
and besides george martin has hinted
that the third dragon rider doesn't
necessarily need to be a targaryen so
maybe tyrion could ride a dragon either
way but the other thing tyrion needs to
resolve are his feelings about taisha
his pain and his longing for his lost
love
will he ever find where [ __ ] go george
martin has said that we will find out
where [ __ ] go so
where
in braavos arya meets a sex worker
called the sailor's wife before she has
sex with men she always marries them in
a fun temporary ceremony with a drunken
priest
like how taisha married tyrion in a fun
ceremony with the drunken priest the
sailor's wife likes singing like how
taisha used to sing for tyrion and she's
a [ __ ] just like taisha was supposedly
a [ __ ] the sailor's wife is a fun and
kind person though there's something sad
about her too
she often prays for her first husband
her true love to come back to her maybe
that husband was tyrion and the sailor's
wife is taisha she could have fled from
westeros and set herself up in braavos
and thing is the sailor's wife has a
blonde daughter called lana lana is 14
years old and taisha and tyrion were
married either 14 or 15 years ago
so the timeline fits lana could be
tyrion lannister's daughter with taisha
there are problems with this theory like
the sailor's wife says her husband was a
sailor and tyrion's not a sailor so
maybe her husband was actually tyrion's
uncle garrion
but the sailor thing could just be a lie
that she tells to protect herself
the other thing is that a fortune teller
says that the sailor's wife's husband is
dead and if he comes back to her it will
be as a corpse
tyrion isn't literally dead but he does
think of himself as being metaphorically
dead having died in king's landing and
become a ghost
so if the sailor's wife is taisha maybe
he will come back to her in braavos
daenerys and tyrion could stop there on
the way west maybe daenerys could borrow
money from the iron bank or fight the
faceless men or something but tyrion and
taisha's reunion may not be a happy one
because tyrion and taisha aren't the
innocent teenagers they remember each
other as tyrion has become a corpse a
hateful murderous version of the boy he
used to be and taisha has ironically
become a [ __ ] which is what tyrion
always feared she was
if a reunion with taisha goes badly and
they don't meet each other's impossible
idealized standards that could push
tyrion into an even darker more
destructive place right as he arrives
back at westeros
so in the next book daenerys will carve
a bloody path across essos with tyrion
by her side tyrion might ride a dragon
he might reunite with taisha and he
might lose or kill penny
the winds of winter has the potential to
be tyrion's darkest book where he fully
embraces fire and blood
at the end of the tv show daenerys burns
king's landing killing thousands of
innocent people out of anger and
frustration and a lot of viewers
complained that this terrible dark turn
happened too suddenly there wasn't
enough build-up and exploration of why
daenerys would do something so evil
in the books her journey across essos
could be that gradual build-up of
destruction
her allies and advisors in the books
will be violent fiery people like
tatters and ben and macquaro the
ironborn and dothraki and tyrion the
devil on her shoulder urging her to burn
westeros for his revenge
the situation in king's landing will be
different it might be aegon not cersei
who has the throne possibly in alliance
with dawn the reach and the faith and
aegon may be popular with the common
people there's a vision of the mama's
dragon amidst a cheering crowd if the
common people support aegon instead of
daenerys daenerys may see the people as
her enemies
john connington could be there and
interestingly jon conn has a traumatic
backstory involving bells which might be
the reason for the bells that ring in
the show before daenerys burns the city
there could also be wildfire in the mix
cersei and jaime might be there perhaps
as prisoners of aegon and the spark
behind the fire could be tyrion
because king's landing is where tyrion
was betrayed by tywin cersei jaime and
shea it's the city he thought to save
before its people rejected and condemned
him he said that he wished he had enough
poison to kill them all and ever since
he's wanted revenge to pay his debts
during robert's rebellion tywin brutally
sacked king's landing killing men women
and children and part of the reason why
he did this so savagely was probably to
get revenge on king aerys and everyone
else who mocked and disrespected him
when he was hand of the king
now tyrion is set to repeat history and
to attack that same city because of how
he was treated when he was hand of the
king tyrion will repeat the sins of his
father
in the show tyrion tells daenerys not to
burn king's landing but in the books he
could encourage or manipulate her into
doing it by turning her against aegon
and the common people or by not telling
her about the dangerous wildfire or even
by starting the fire himself on a dragon
of his own however it happens the
burning of king's landing would be the
ultimate expression of all tyrion's
hatred and pain especially if it kills
jaime and cersei
but revenge won't make tyrion happy in
the end in book 5 he has a dream where
he fights a battle with dragons overhead
he kills tywin and he kills jaime but
then tyrion realizes he's crying as
ellaria says revenge doesn't fix
anything it doesn't bring back what
you've lost a skull can't make you happy
in the show tyrion walks through the
ashes of king's landing and cries over
the bodies of jaime and cersei the
tragedy in the show is that tyrion
failed to protect his family but in the
books the tragedy could be that he
killed his family and only realized it
was a mistake when it was too late
in the show bran makes tyrion hand of
the king and says he'll work to fix his
terrible mistakes but tyrion's terrible
mistake in the tv show was believing in
daenerys who turned evil despite his
good intentions it could be so much more
tragic in the books if tyrion's mistake
is encouraging daenerys's violence
choosing hate and revenge
so
will tyrion end the series as a villain
like tywin or could he redeem himself
in the show the white walkers are
defeated then king's landing burns but
in the books it might be the other way
around because jon killing daenerys
makes more sense in the context of the
white walkers because of the azor ahai
story so maybe after tyrion and daenerys
burn king's landing tyrion will help
defeat the white walkers he could
finally realize that saving the world is
more important than his politics and
revenge the night's watch were right
this is what he should have been doing
all along when tyrion stood on the wall
in book one he felt something he sensed
that the white walkers were the true
enemy he could help them by riding a
dragon maybe or just help politically by
building alliances with the starks
tyrion and jon still think of each other
as friends and tyrion has relationships
with bran and his wife sansa so maybe
tyrion will team up with the starks and
redeem himself by saving the world from
the white walkers
or maybe that's too much of a happy
ending maybe tyrion deserves punishment
characters talk about cutting out
tyrion's tongue eight times in the books
because tyrion constantly annoys people
with his jokes and insults and his words
cause so much trouble removing someone's
tongue is a common punishment in
westeros euron greyjoy often cuts out
people's tongues and he's becoming a
major bad guy in the books he might take
tyrion's dragon viserion and then take
tyrion's tongue
cersei is another possibility she hates
tyrion and she's been talking a lot
about cutting out tongues lately and
tyrion losing his tongue would fit a
pattern with his siblings because each
of the lannisters lose the part of
themselves that gives them power and
pride jaime loses his hand that made him
a great warrior cersei loses her image
as a proud beautiful queen in her walk
of shame and tyrion's power and pride is
in his sharp witty tongue so if he loses
his tongue all three lannisters will
have lost their most important part
when jaime loses his hand and bran
breaks his back and arya loses her sight
these are challenges that force the
characters to grow and redefine
themselves but tyrion has kind of
already had his downfall he's already
lost everything so losing his tongue
might not be about growing his character
it could be more of a brutal final
tragedy at the end of his story
a punishment for all his crimes because
if tyrion's words and lies convince
daenerys to burn king's landing maybe
king bran will take tyrion's tongue so
his words can't do evil again he could
live out his days as a quiet lion at
casterly rock or as a mute maester at
the citadel or with the night's watch
tyrion remembers that joe mormont said
that they need men like tyrion in the
watch tyrion remembers that the watch
welcomes outcasts and misfits no matter
their past crimes maybe with the
brotherhood of the watch tyrion will
finally find the family and acceptance
he's always wanted sam says that someone
really needs to sort out the books in
the castle black library which will take
years of work but sam will be busy being
grand maester so maybe tyrion will sort
out the books at the watch
tyrion's first chapter begins with him
reading a book that was always his
comfort and his escape so maybe the
series will end with tyrion reading a
book
quietly
so is tyrion lannister a villain from
the beginning tyrion felt unloved and
rejected so he used political power to
try to earn some respect but then he was
betrayed and condemned by all the people
closest to him tyrion falls deep into
despair and hate and dreams of revenge
in the next book he may embrace fire and
blood he might spark the burning of
king's landing but he might also help
save the world from the white walkers
tyrion is villainous he is a hateful
ruthless murderer like his father but he
is also heroic he's sometimes kind
protective and brave
george martin did once call tyrion a
villain but he more often calls tyrion
morally grey
martin writes about the human heart in
conflict with itself and no one's heart
is more conflicted than tyrion's
there's love and hate good and evil
inside him and to be human is to look
for the light
if you want the real story of game of
thrones you've got to check out the
books the main series and the prequel
stories and the history books you can
get any one of these on audiobook for
free right now at audible.com asx sign
up for a premium plus trial membership
and you get an audiobook to keep even if
you cancel the trial you could get dune
or wheel of time or the expanse
membership also includes unlimited
access to thousands of audio books and
shows in the audible plus catalog sign
up at audible.com asx or text asx to 500
500.
there's still more to say about tyrion
so there'll be a q a live stream on this
channel in a few days at the link below
also alt schwift x has released a rap
about tyrion for some reason so you can
check that out but don't encourage him
thanks to the artists and fan essayists
linked below and thanks to the patrons
including kiara and karth eli lidkia j
valk michelle dan marks mally brossett
lady diana cali havimaki and carla
lindemann cheers